Thomas agab
Benny thank you I'm here on behalf of Mr
call Paladino as a candidate for
governor Mr Paladino want everybody to
know here that he doesn't think that
this is a political issue his view is
that it's an issue that involves
fundamental respect for American values
for our soldiers who go to war and
defend our freedom and for the 3,000
American ANS including First Responders
who died on September 11th in
2001 and what did they die from they
died from religious intolerance and
violence and
now in the year 2010 we want to approve
a building which is a symbol of the
religion that spawned that intolerance
and violence this is an
affront this is an affront to the
families of those who died to the
families of the soldiers and the
American soldiers who defend our freedom
frankly I hope that we haven't
collectively lost all our minds this
isn't about religious freedom if it were
about religious freedom we wouldn't be
here discussing it the fact is it's
simply about the sighting of a structure
we're not opposed to people practicing
their religion and practicing the
freedom that's what America stands for
but what we're not going to tolerate is
the religion that caused the death of
those Americans at the Hallowed Ground
of Ground Zero building a mosque with a
$100 million of blood money from around
this world that hasn't even been
investigated and I can tell you this if
this board doesn't act Mr Paladino has
authorized me to make the suggestion
that Senator Schumer Senator gillibrand
and our our delegation to Washington has
the power through the war memorial act
to make that a national War Memorial
monument and prevent
any structures being built there that
are an affront to the people of this
country and it's an insult that the good
people have to come here and actually
beg to have this landmarked the last
thing that we want is the religion that
spawned this violence to build a
structure that's a poking eye to every
American and everyone who suffered on
911 and you have to make sure it is your
responsibility to make sure that that
doesn't happen thank you much thank you
thank
you okay Jacqueline kochek I'm going to
call some more names please thank
you good afternoon Mr Tierney chairman
tiany and the rest of the members of
this Council my name is jacen cochelle I
am in no way related to any attorneys or
economic interests in this issue I do
have a life that has been spent in
Memorial moralizing history and
particularly the hearts of people in
historic times I have uh done many
historic singing projects and was
endorsed by the Abraham Lincoln by
Centennial commission for my Abraham
Lincoln singing history
project as an example of what history
means to people I would cite the Ford
Theater which in no way is a beautiful
building but to have allowed the Ford
Theater to be destroyed and put up a
monument to
reconstructionism is the equivalent of
what is being suggested
here by your own words in this piece of
paper which I was given when I entered
it says that one must consider Heritage
and cultural
characteristics in considering
landmarking and by the very Words which
were first given to us by your
spokeswoman at the beginning of the
meeting she said the Builders of the
mertile structures
4547 Parkplace sought to project an
image of prestige and economic power I
think this is quite amazing that that is
what that building was built to
represent because that is exactly what
the Twin Towers represented in this
country Prestige and economic power and
and that is why they were chosen to be
destroyed by a group of people whose
goal it is to Wi to destroy the American
way of life and to inflict another way
of life upon
us um that is precisely why they were
chosen therefore it is cynical to
suggest that this building be destroyed
so that an an example of what represents
that very group of people be allowed to
be erected and and signify Prestige and
E economic power on their part um it is
over the centuries uh an action that
Islam has taken repeatedly the
destruction of the famous St John's
Church the erection there on that very
place of a mosque the choice of putting
a mosque over the Wailing Wall in
Jerusalem this is not an isolated
incident this is a very carefully
planned effort on the part of radical
islamists I also single-handedly created
the committee to save the theaters in
this city I I was the one that created
that committee and I beg you to respect
the heart of the American people who
will be deeply pained if they have an
infliction of of a representation of the
very people who destroyed 3,000 innocent
lives thank you thank you thank you
thank you very
much is William a William avalo
here uh then let me call Jake ittz
representing
councilwoman Margaret chin who signed up
Jake where are you there you go okay
uh thank you Mr chair members of the
commission
um the council member just would like to
go on record at the hearing um and I
just want to say thank you from her end
and from my from my uh end for being
here all day and uh taking all this
public testimony um the council member
has been and would like to be on record
as uh opposing the designation of the uh
building at 45 uh Parkplace as a
landmark uh and would like to Echo the
sentiments of the community board one uh
resolution with the exception that we
don't necessarily believe that the
facade what other parts of the external
structure of the building uh meet the
criteria to be landmarked thank you for
your time and your attention thank you
thank you very much Mike Longo is Mike
Longo
here glennis James
glennis Carmen
Clinton Carmen
Clinton oh please
hi um
Carman Carman Clinton sure um I'd like
for the panel to give some serious
consideration to doing due diligent
oversight for where the money is going
to come
from to build this mosque more
importantly I need to know to some
satisfaction how many people are is this
MOS going to serve
cuz I can't see Wall Street teaming with
Muslims okay I mean it's just not
happening okay
and for the Muslim people to want to
come here and take part of our
freedoms and then try
to run us over with their wealth with
their worry and with their weird words
all right if we don't give them status
is this young lady going to be spat with
explosives and sent down there to
detonate how do you know I'm you do it
now please continue your testimony okay
right conclude it wind up if you can
please thank you okay J we no we know
how how dare you how dare you how dare
you you continue the testimony or you
can have I am
froms and I will not and I and I will
not stand down I wasn't there but I I
was killed by TV on
911 other members of my family were
given aiding Comfort to the First
Responders so I know the pain and the
hurt that was there and for these people
who think nothing of chopping off
somebody's head for take your testimony
to the landmarking or the non
landmarking fine if you allow them to
have that then you are a part of the
worry and the wars that we're going to
have because they want to force the
issue and not accept the change thank
you thank you very
much
Fran please Fran
bin hello I'm sorry
hello my name is glennice James um I'm a
native New Yorker I've born and raised
in New York City I've spent most of my
life working in the downtown area I even
spent some years working in the World
Trade Center and although I didn't lose
anyone on 911 I I feel like I was
strongly affected as all New Yorkers
were strongly affected by what happened
on that day okay um however I love this
city I love my country and I love the
Constitution and the First Amendment
rights of the United States of America
and one of my fears is that has been
that I would hate to see our society
slip into one which is ruled by faar and
allows fear to trample on the civil
rights of fellow citizens in this
country I it kind of puts me in my kind
of reminds me of what happened to the
Japanese American citizens after Pro
haror okay um all I want to say is
if you're deciding whether or not the
building is a landmark based on
historical or whatever other reasons
then that should be your criteria you
should be basing it on whether it truly
is a landmark building not because um of
a fear of having a mo build there or any
other type of building built there um I
don't think that a fair should be the
criteria um if if it's based on whether
the owner um needs to be investigated
then let that be done okay but I think
that as
Americans we show I mean the soldiers
are fighting for the protection of the
Constitution of the United States and
First Amendment rights as well and and
so I don't see how I really don't see
how building a mosque is a contradiction
to um American values I mean
um it's I mean it's even so but but just
by saying that it shouldn't be there
because of location you're implying that
there's something inherently wrong with
that religion oh well you know what the
largest terrorist organization in the
United States of America has been the
clue clus Clan they claim to be
Christians they are okay no we haven't
they still exist and but anyway please
only statement was that it should be a
decision if it's a l if it is a
historical Lama and that's the ruling
because it is a historical lount fine
but the decision shouldn't be made
because oh you're afraid that something
else is going to be built there
understood thank you thank you very much
next
speaker yes Michael Charles
Longo Native
American my heart Grieves this country I
got to take time off from what's going
on in this world to come down here and
talk about
this you all want to know about Islam
and a lot of questions 40 times it's
mentioned in in the book Jihad 36 of
those 40 they're talking about a holy
war and if you read the
book The fine
line lying is okay as long as it
promotes
the
religion this is still a Christian
country and you people are going to be
held accountable accountable if this
goes through thank you very much bless
you thank you I have concluded calling
names so if there are other people who
have either signed up and I called
earlier please come down to the mics now
and state your name and testify thank
you hi I'm B paluch I testified earlier
I just wanted to yeah uh talk to you a
little bit about I'm an artist and I
remember years ago reading something in
the papers about the landmark
preservation commission helping a
developer or a building owner create a
faux Cas IR building okay you can't
testify twice but I understand your
point that's that's that's fine but we
need other people who haven't testified
need to speak I just want to say if you
protecting that if you so cared about
these cine buildings to help that person
create that faux ctin building then why
not protect this one too it's a real one
we understood thank you please
ma'am samum peace be upon you everyone
Shalom hello Allah every language I
can't think of any more languages to say
hello or peace be upon you I think
that's about it but today I'm here to
say that a mosque should be built
because it does promote Interfaith
dialogue and over here a lot of people
are telling me what I'm about that I'm
about blowing up things and people
people are telling me that I'm about
Jihad do you guys even know what Jihad
is g no you guys don't please address
the Commission address your testimony to
us landmarking issue Jihad means to
sacrifice what's in your heart for Islam
it's not about sacrificing other people
it's about standing up for peace for
Interfaith dialogue that is what Islam
is about and all you people here yelling
at me don't even know and maybe if a
mosque were built then you guys would
know what Islam was about and my parents
my family died that day so how dare you
tell me that this is not my country that
that I have no concerned over this cuz
they died that day all right they died
that day and I'm for it
why you betraying them I'm not betraying
them cuz they believed they believed in
peace they believed in people together
and that day my aunts my family they
were thrown Tomatoes at is that an act
that's an act of terrorism
too objects were thrown at them too and
honestly that day death does not
discriminate cuz Muslims died that day
too Muslims died that day too and
everybody who died would probably want a
MOS buil so everybody understands what
Islam is about thank you yes they would
thank
you please the testimony is directed
toward the commission and thank you very
much for next on the other mic thank you
very much thank you my name is Mark
Greenberg I'm a New Yorker I'm an
American and I'm a
Jew 2700 New Yorkers Christians Jews
Muslims and other people of Faith died
by
9/11 and as we know all th those deaths
were the result of an act of a small
number of radicals and I would say
deranged and insane men in the name of
Islam just over 50 years ago nearly 6
million Jews were extermin exterminated
by a regime of deranged and insane men
representing the government of
Germany in the Middle Ages thousands of
Europeans were massacred by derang and
insane people in the name of
Christianity the 19 40s our great
country out of fear and hysteria forced
tens of thousands of Japanese Americans
into internment camps now thank God most
of us realize how wrong that
was this room was understandably filled
with the horror of 911 but to blame our
moderate Muslim brothers and sisters for
the horror of 9/11 would be just as
wrong as blaming all Germans for the
Holocaust to blame all Japanese for
portl Harbor or to to blame all
Christians for the Crusades I must say
to hear someone talk about building a
monument to
terrorism is very disturbing even to
characterize this project as a 15-story
mosque is inaccurate at best it's my
understanding the Cordoba initiative
would be a Muslim sponsored Community
Center to serve people of all faiths and
people of no faith as a place for public
Gatherings for people of all faiths for
weddings Bar Mitzvah a library a gym a
place for classes a place for public
discourse and our gathering today
clearly demonstrates the need for public
Dialogue on issues of faith and
Multicultural relations if we as a
society are to have a dialogue with
moderate Islamic community and build a
greater dialogue between members of our
community and the City of in a city of
different face this is the opportunity
to do just that as Americans and those
who feel the loss and horror of 911 I
challenge all of us to find the courage
to really live out the words the land of
the free and the home of the brave and
to reach out to those who are offering
to establish Community Center to serve
all of downtown to serve all of the city
and use this as a demonstration that New
York is bit bigger than our fear I don't
blame those who oppose this project for
being bigots or racist I believe that
rather they're misinformed unaware of
the fact that the vast majority of
Muslims are decent loving people and the
vast vast majority of American Muslims
love America and the vast majority of
Muslims were as horrified as all
Americans by what was done in the name
of Islam on
911 I say that to welcome the supporters
of the Cordova initiative in their
effort to
demonstrate okay time thank you thank
you hello please thank you thank you
very much I would say that to welcome
the supporters of the initiative in
their effort to demonstrate their love
and respect for this city and for
America by establishing a center to
serve all New Yorkers is a decent thing
to do a brave thing to do an American
thing to
do we understand the feelings of pain
and loss and fear are much more intense
in the feelings that many of that that
many of us has for dialogue and
partnership however what we must do to
move forward to help find peace is a
reach for dialogue rather than act out
of fear I oppose landmarking of Park
Place thank you thank you very much over
here and then we'll go back please okay
can I yeah I'd like to ask this question
I'm not against Muslims per se I'm not
against Arabs per se but one thing
troubles
me whenever Muslims speak the so-called
moderate Muslims they always talk about
oh Islam is a religion of Peace most
Muslims are not violent so for like that
but they start condemning the people who
are afraid of Muslims there is good Reon
reason why many people were afraid of
the
Muslims we need we need we need to
address the landmark issue for us if you
well I want to say because this is long
before uh 2 between 2001 there was these
the hamash the PLO all of them they have
been violent in Israel they've been
violent in India they're violent in
Europe This is a whole thing going on
for the last 40 years and and the fact
of the matter is I only hear from all
all I hear from 1.5 billion Muslims in
the world all I hear is the ones the
ones who supposedly are against all of
this violence they say well Islam is not
a religion of violence but why don't you
address yourself why don't they address
themselves to why people are afraid of
the Muslims why instead of saying these
people are fear mongers and and and and
hysterical there was good reason anyway
thank you thank you
next thank you hello sir how you doing
sir my name is John klanova I'm a
longtime resident of New York City uh I
spent nine months down to Ground Zero uh
doing recovery
work I want to see the designation The
Landmark designation for this there's a
lot of reasons I think you've heard them
all today it's not a beautiful building
there's nothing anything special about
it uh it is part of New York City
Heritage it is part of of the ground
zero experience that we went through and
and the attack on Ground Zero but one of
the things I don't understand with the
Muslim Community is that there is such
opposition from this why don't they just
say hey hey you know we want to show
tolerance let's move this someplace else
let's take it away from here but all I
actually do see sir is they're dividing
us and one thing I've learned a long
time ago is when you divide you conquer
and I think this is their stamp this is
their stamp by getting this there
they're saying not only we divided them
but we've conquered them we've caused
total Discord amongst a community a
family of New Yorkers and like we said
no one goes out of their way like New
Yorkers and gentlemen and ladies I'm
asking you I've been involved in a
little bit of uh work with you guys
before in the past and there was
sometimes I I would come to a meeting
and I say they've already made this
decision and I'm starting to get that
feeling about this guys and ladies I
just don't understand why the landmark
commission just doesn't say hey you know
what it does have some significance to
us it is it is where our people were
which what let's do this let's offer
let's offer the community something
outside of this area we're not saying
you can't put up your Masque but we just
don't want it there and I want to see
some tolerance to us we lost 3,000
people we've lost over 5,000 people
overseas right now I've got family in
the military and I worry about them
every day and you know who they're
fighting they're fighting Muslims we
can't allow this right now this is very
serious this should be landmarked you
know what let's Landmark it let's give
them a little piece of that thing let's
put up a a let's make our tribute Center
in this building and then let's see how
tolerant they are this is all I'm asking
sir I think I'm hoping you didn't make
up your decision thank you sir thank you
very much yes ma'am next over here hi my
name is Francesca Bugan this is my
daughter this is what this is what I
want to be able to see what America is
when I on
9/11 I was walking my dog and I watched
watched one building come down and I
stood in Long Island City looking
across at that one building thinking how
disturbing that is there's only one
building
there we are talking about
keeping another building that was
standing
there we're talking about
keeping a record for our
children my daughter my daughter her
name is Eden after the garden I believe
in God I believe there is one God and I
believe that Jewish
Christian Muslim Buddhist we all pray to
that one God and every one of you
sitting up
there comes from that and our country is
built with the understanding that our
power and our rights and our beliefs and
what we live for is to honor
that on 911 I walked down Steinway
Street in atoria and I walked in front
of a mosque where people were standing
in the street
going yes yes this is wonderful what
just happened across the river I was
standing in front of a mosque now I do
not blame all Muslim people for what
happened on that day but I
do think that there is plenty of space
to build a beautiful mosque to honor
God anywhere
else anywhere else and I do not think
that a building that was standing there
should be taken down
when enough already went
down thank you thank you very
much please find it in your heart in
your soul in your mind and pray pray
pray to your God to give you the right
guidance ladies and gentlemen this is on
you thank you thank you very much over
here hello my name is Kathleen santor um
I'm not here representing any political
party but I'm representing my family my
brother was a 23-year-old firefighter
who died on
911 and um to me that ground at Ground
Zero is sacred okay um many people most
of them actually never recovered their
family members of their loved ones and
that's their burial ground we don't have
any place to go to pray there's not even
a memorial there yet for us to go and I
believe it's disrespectful a slap in the
face and inappropriate to erect a mosque
in such proximity such close proximity
to this sacred ground where to the
families of 911 and and to all New
Yorkers and and all of America that's
what we have that's what we have to
remember you know a lot of people before
me spoke and they said pretty much the
same thing that I wanted to say and it I
mean I can't strike my point home any
harder but this is one of the only
remaining buildings that we
have you can't take that away from us to
put up any cultural center mosque
whatever even if it was a shopping
center it it can't be there it has to
remain where it is the fact that it want
you know they want to make it in mosque
is even more of a disrespectful insult
in my
opinion um than anything else and I I
don't understand why we even have to be
here having this forum when it should
the decision should be intrinsically
clear to everybody I don't you know um I
don't know much about laws and and about
the politics of things but um I do
believe what's right is what everybody
know I think everybody believes in their
heart and what Americans should hold
true to themselves and their values and
I don't know where what happened to that
I don't know where it is and um I hope
that
you guys make the right decision thank
you and um you know everybody in this
room you know pretty much understands
the reasons why the people who who are
in favor of the landmarking are in favor
of it it's not out of fear it's not
because uh we're bigots you know I'm
tired of hearing everybody get up here
and say those things but it's about
doing what's right okay amen that's
that's all I have to say thank you oh
yes sir just very briefly um Mike just
call me Chuck
um you I have nothing against the Muslim
people for the most part they think
they're doing the right thing I
believe you've already testified yes I
have I just want to say I would like to
put a church here at this address 45
Parkplace that's all okay a Christian
church amen and and a memorial center
for the yeah okay God bless you yes Dr
sidiki from inward section of New York
City I see it's very nice that democracy
is actually in action I'm also grateful
to the people and citizens of New York
City for showing their understanding
during that
crisis my city has lot of beautiful
monuments they are very out
understanding let us add one more to
peace and Universal Brotherhood and that
would be the card of a mask thank
you thank
you anyone else to be
heard quickly
please let's keep the landmark no
mask keep the landmark this is America
and I'm sick and tired of them calling
us tea party people and life was bigots
I'm involved in pro life okay a religion
that sends his people to
attack to kill 3,000 people you know God
he's pro-life he's not pro death and and
they were murderers that did that and we
stand up for Life America that a right
to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness from conception to Natural
death and these bums I saw those tired I
didn't lose anybody but I'm devastated
to this day because when I got down
there I thought it was a little accident
I thought it was a little plane that
cross a private plane somebody I was
staying on a little 20ft boat up in the
Harlem River up in Manhattan and one of
the transit workers the transit yard
says a plane crashed into the into the
World Trade Center I thought the whole
thing was an accident I go down there
couldn't get any
further then uh Chris uh Christian uh
Christopher Sheridan Street I think it
was then I get out there and I see that
I said my God there's hundreds of people
there they were burned to death or they
fell 1,000 ft rather than to die by
burning they were crushed to death when
that whole building came
down you know never again man let's
stand up for America let's stand up for
the babies let's stand up for the ter
shos that were murdered I went down to
Florida because that tore me apart what
they did to that woman
let's stand up for life and if they call
them what kind of religion is it that
they'll send those people down there to
kill our people and then then sometimes
I see people uh one guy was even saying
oh conclude the testimony got to wind up
but
anyway up a religion that's a religion
God is prolife and anything other than
that is not a religion understood okay
thank you very much thank you thank you
anyone else they turn the Constitution
into the constipation of declaration
independence of Declaration ofest and we
got to fix it thank you thank you we are
going to conclude the day we close the
hearing and thank everyone for being
here take a motion to close the hearing
a second without objection the hearing
is closed thank you
[Music]
mic's off